along the road North of harkib city
sunflower fields are left to rot this is
harvest season and much of the seeds
were destined to the international
markets
many of the fields are now riddled with
landmines and there aren't many farmers
left in the region these rural areas
towards the border with Russia have come
under constant shelling the main
hospital targeted repeatedly there's
only one building left standing treated
rooms had to be moved to the underground
shelters but over the last few days
there are less wounded but the colony
tells me that the Ukrainian forces still
come under attack
we're at the northern edge of Ukraine
this is actually the beginning of the
Border area Russia being only about
three kilometers away from here now it's
only since a few days that calm has been
restored In This Place The Villages
around here had come under constant
cross-border shelling since the
beginning of the war now Ukraine claims
that some of its forces have reached
several points along the border with
Russia there's no trace of Russian
forces here after Ukraine started it's
counter-offensive in the northeast of
the country Russia announced it had
pulled out all of its troops from the
kharkiv region
the heaviest presence was further south
along the road more evidence of an Army
on the Run leaving everything behind
in the village of Iraq people are
already fixing their homes this man
tells me they were given orders to stay
at home despite the damage and bombing
many soldiers were living in houses of
people who fled to safety a warning on
this door says beware of mines
Russia still holds air superiority and
is targeting infrastructure around the
country a dam near the hometown of
president zielinski was struck causing
major flooding in Creve
Ukraine is gaining momentum but there is
still more than 2 500 kilometers of
Front Line before it can call Victory if
anything this counter-offensive has
risen the spirits of a country under
attack
in the kharkiv region